all right how's it going everyone p25
hair period ha what the crisis - comment
area I kind of feel like these aren't
really commentaries anymore because
they're more like logs to be honest I I
guess again please that they're for
those who enjoy that sort of stuff like
I said it's a demo I don't remember if I
said it though but I don't know it's
it's a lot of fun actually and I wish I
could afford buying the game a lot of
people have been asking me order you're
going to get crisis - um new dancer is
new I wish I could and but there's a lot
of other games coming up this year like
mmm portal - I really want to get that
game I really really want to get that
the game and bring a lot of stuff coming
out basically
maybe if I were a rich guy maybe I'm a
rich guy yeah I don't think that's the
lyrics but anyway I have a lot of stuff
to talk about so I'll just get started I
guess first of all I have a Facebook
page I'm going to leave the link down
below and my pants which all the Google
kids say um some of you have a well a
lot of you actually have been saying hi
and stuff already and it's it's a lot of
fun - I don't know and get the chance to
see your face and not just some random
made-up word name or whatever it's fun
to see who watch my videos and stuff and
so yeah if you want to go go over there
and say how I like it or whatever you
want to do that's fine and I think in
this gameplay I actually figured out how
to use the killstreaks for the first
time it's kind of different you have to
walk over the you have to walk a look at
this nade fail you have to walk over the
guy you killed to get the kill streak
and it took me forever to figure that
out so there you go if you haven't
played it already and you're about to
and I get the
I got to like the leash thing that pops
out of the sky like ground I was like oh
my I'm a shot here my laser is so
awesome you'll see it eventually so what
else I wanted to talk about was I was
about I was going to get a going to get
I have been offered to if this channel
would be partnered by machinima which is
a great offer I'll make money of the
videos and the there is a catch though
there will be ads and stuff which makes
oh there's a laser home alone
that's amazing it's really really easy
to get distracted when playing this game
it looks awesome really they've made an
amazing job when they made this game
Crysis 1 was like our benchmark and for
PC gamers like if you had a new computer
the first thing you'll ask them was like
oh can it run Crysis oh we can't get in
not really but it was something like
that again I kind of feel like we lost
that touch now that a lot of them you
know it's ported to consoles and stuff
but whatever who gives a crap really
they got to make money at the end of the
day so yeah feel free to leave your
thoughts about the partnership thing if
you I can totally understand if people
are against the idea of having ads on
the videos and stuff so feel free to
leave your thoughts I just wanted to ask
you guys first uh what else what else I
was gonna do livestream yeah how do you
suggested it I have done a livestream
before it was a lot of fun hanging out
with you guys I guess it would I thought
it was going to be me doing like you
live calm like I usually do but people
you guys were like so active in the
Shatt it was like impossible for me to
like focus on the game and a lot of
questions were thrown at me at once and
it was like really difficult to focus
but it was a lot of fun like I said I
love to do it again I was thinking maybe
next Wednesday at 9
yeah 9 9 a.m. from a and 2 p.m. that's
how I remember it by the way I always
think of that song you know somebody
hits a light so we crocodilla night and
I don't know Nana from a and 2 p.m. okay
that was the gayest thing I ever said
actually I said a lot more gay things
and I'm really glad you guys are
enjoying the less place even though I
just spout like gay jokes and penis and
stuff like that uh but yeah it's all
good at the end of the day I guess so
yeah if you want to also suggest suggest
like a game I'm gonna play in the
livestream or whatever and I'll probably
do it probably not a scary game though I
think it will it will feel weird knowing
that there's like live people watching
me and I don't know it cannot feel like
that room ruins the mood or whatever and
I hope you're getting with that as well
I guess we could talk about the game a
little bit guess I'm pretty much done
with all this stuff I wanted to talk
about and I really think that this map
is really cool it's supposed to be like
a my [ __ ] computer goes to
screensaver sometimes and well not
sometimes every 5 minutes for some
reason whatever it's like an ascribed
skyscraper on New York and if you think
about like every futuristic scenario
it's always the same it's also all we
polluted the earth and everything is
dead and stuff it's all dark here the
candidate took a different approach and
it's like we have trees and stuff
growing on top of the building and like
power plants like wind power plants and
stuff and I don't know I just thought I
was kind of cool that they were actually
original and cannot cannot
Kame Kame why is that so hard to say I I
keep waiting for like that's what she
said but whatever I think this is pretty
much wrapping up I hope you have a nice
weekend I gotta try to do these weekly
it's a lot of fun to check in with you
guys every now and then and you know see
how what's up basically
did I say I was going to play Black
Plague I am actually going to play black
Lee but I have no more time to talk so
I'm going to sign off these pretty paths
ending up here the pack